all right at some point the cowboys are
going to be paying far more than 90
million dollars to dak prescott there's
a belief in league circles that he just
needs to get his deal done by this
weekend that having 2 million as his
compensation for this year with no
guarantee no protection no security
beyond this season you can't say no to
that offer that's on the table whatever
that offer is you can't say no to it
because even though quarterbacks are
protected injuries happen just look at
alex smith last year and his broken leg
should he take whatever the best offer
is should he take it when the weekend
rolls over well i mean it depends on
what that best offer is i mean i think
if it's like down in like you know jimmy
garoppolo territory no i i understand
him not wanting to do that don't be
pressured into it you've definitely
earned the right to make more than jimmy
garoppolo i mean i would think dak
prescott and his camp especially right
now we're going okay
we can understand maybe not getting as
much as jared goff we're cool with that
his resume what he's done okay but then
they're going to look at carson wins and
go but we do feel like you know our
player has a leg up on carson wentz now
you know again i think carson wins the
most talented of all of them but the
fact of the matter is you know carson
wentz has been hurt and last year it
wasn't great early on in the year and
all those things that prescott's gone to
the playoffs never missed three years i
know right so they're gonna have that
argument to where if it is somewhere
between goff and wentz i hope he takes
it and moves on and secures his family
and future livelihood within signing
that contract and you mentioned jimmy
garoppolo and let me just reiterate this
point and this is one of the things that
drives me crazy about how the nfl and
the nfl pa and agents and teams value
contracts because if as of right now you
take the one year left on dak prescott's
deal and rip it up and give him the same
contract that jimmy garoppolo got from
the 49ers early 2018. five years 27.5
million per year right now right at
signing that's the value that would be
fair that would be more than fair right
the way that it works is that gets
reported by the nfl players association
as a deal that would have an average
value of 34 million a year because if
you pay five years 27 and a half million
per year you have to factor in he was
only gonna make two million this year so
it becomes a four-year extension for all
that new money right and it pumps up to
34 million a year and that's that's one
of the reasons why i think they haven't
gotten this done yeah because when you
view it as 34 million people like how in
the hell is dak prescott worth 34
million a year well hang on is he worth
five years 27 and a half million remove
the current deal that he has left and
given that people say well yeah that's
more than reasonable right and that's
that drives me crazy well hopefully the
cowboys aren't being petty about that
well i mean you know to me too why do
you care if the public thinks it's 34 in
but you're really paying them 27. that
should be a good deal for them right i
mean would you think not or no i think i
think
that it would be and i'd like to see
somebody other than me yeah stand up and
explain this distinction everybody goes
crazy yeah because here's the thing the
teams it helps the teams because
they act like they feel they're paying
more than they really are yeah you know
oh we're paying them 34 million a year
we can't do that well you're not you're
paying 27.5 million yeah let the player
think he's making 34 million a year or
at least the public thinks that yeah but
but that they they're worried about the
way they use it to squeeze them down
squeeze them down or other agents use it
to squeeze them eventually to say you're
paying this guy this much per year i
just think it's a bad way of valuing
these contracts because there is no such
thing as an extension folks what they do
is they do an entirely new contract that
begins right now they rip up the old one
and they replace it with the new one it
is not an extension it's a new deal will
it get done do you think he signs a new
deal before sunday yes you do yes wow
yeah you've been kind of all over this
crap so for some reason i don't know i
don't know any guts been good ladies i
feel like thank you yeah lots of pasta
and meatballs in there it's been good
it's been a long off season it's been a
good off season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports